monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre on achète des œufs venus de
l'étranger pondus dans les cages que
nous avons vendues des cerises parce
qu'on a arraché les cerisiers et bientôt
pommier et noisetier on va acheter le
poisson déchargé de bateau battant
pavillon étranger parce qu'on a détruit
on détruit notre flotte alors qu'on se
tarde d'avoir le deuxième domaine
maritime mondial déjà les fruits et
légumes faute de main d'oeuvre peut-être
les endives laissées en terre faute à
une énergie trop cher combat de
concurrents de DF le sucre ou les
lentilles malgré le plan protéines
importées de pays où sont autorisés des
traitements interdits ici ajoutez à sa
l'angoisse des règlements des contrôles
des injonctions contradictoires des
charges administratives et l'incertitude
des revenus soumis au négociations
annuelles vous voyez le comte de fées ne
fait pas rêver la profession agricole
qui s'interroge sur la place réelle et
l'avenir que vous lui réservez la ferme
de France exposée à ces rencontres
s'exposent cette semaine en lettres
capitales pour proclamer la qualité des
productions et l'engagement des hommes
et des femmes pour des produits
respectueux des exigences sanitaires et
durables protégées les consommateurs et
notre environnement croyez-vous que les
agriculteurs refusent de mettre des six
pans pour répandre plus de nitrates dont
les coûts ont plus que triplés
croyez-vous que les agriculteurs ou les
industriels ont attendu les déclarations
du président parlant de l'eau sur la fin
de l'abondance pour l'économiser alors
que les entreprises comme Cristal Union
dans la Somme
uselot même des betteraves pour leur
cycles de production de sucre et ne
puise rien dans les nappes pour gagner
en compétitivité et répondre aux
exigences environnementales
l'agriculture est soumise à la nature et
au temps faites-vous résigner le choix
de son déclin ou d'une agriculture
vitrifiée et d'importation ou in vitro
peut-être la ferme France a besoin de
connaître le cap pour qu'elle adapte son
évolution dépendant de la recherche
technique génétique les moyens alloués
et le pas de temps nécessaire ce temps
politique c'est maintenant monsieur le
ministre quel est votre ambition